[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock when is a party
not a party dining street has
consistently denied any such event took
place just before christmas last year
when social mixing indoors was banned in
the capital yet leaked footage shows the
prime minister's then press secretary
and his adviser joking about
a downing street christmas event with
cheese and wine normally at this point
i'll tell you who's joining us from the
government to answer questions put to by
me for you on your behalf but despite
assurances we'd have a minister with us
no one appears to be available but with
plenty of reaction from those who'd like
some answers also this morning for you
she's the woman who broke the glass
ceiling and became one of the fbi's top
serial killer specialists we'll speak
with pioneering forensic nurse ann
walbert burgess
and
the impact of music therapy for patsy
has given her opportunity it's been
amazing life changing in fact
[Music]
discussing the return of the nordoff
robbins christmas concert as we talk
with the families with autistic children
that they help it's wednesday the 8th of
december
party politics calls for resignations in
downing street after leaked footage
shows staff discussing an apparent
gathering there last christmas
i had just seen reports from twitter
that there was a downing street
christmas party on friday night do you
recognize those reports
i went home
[Laughter]
just how festive was the cheer behind
the doors of number ten
several of the pm staff facing calls to
quit over claims of celebrations while
the nation was under lockdown what the
prime minister needs to step up uh
accept what happened and apologize
unfortunately we've got a prime minister
who is socially distant from the truth
plus the department of education admits
that the former education secretary
gavin williamson arranged an office
celebration at his office last december
a year on we marked the anniversary of
the first coronavirus vaccine being
administered in the uk
while there are celebrations to mark the
breakthrough some scientists are warning
about the growing dangers of the new
omicron variant
govid fraud scanias reveals fake vaccine
passports which could allow tourists to
enter the uk they're on sale across
europe
i'm live here in port call for day two
of storm borough the highest wind speeds
in wales yesterday 86 miles per hour
the boycott builds australia joins the
united states in its diplomatic boycott
of the beijing winter olympics
[Music]
good morning pmq should be an incredibly
good watch this lunchtime with boris
johnson facing questions about what
exactly happened inside number 10 a week
before christmas last year the
government's consistently denied that a
party took place saying no rules were
broken while the country was under
strict lockdown
yet leaked footage has emerged showing
the pm's then press secretary and top
advisers joking about reports of a party
a cheese and wine event in fact with no
social distancing now normally we'd ask
a government minister about this we were
told originally that it was going to be
the health secretary sanji javid because
of course it's the first anniversary of
the first vaccine being administered but
now we've been told that sadly no one's
actually accepted our invitation we've
not even had a proper rsvp never mind
here's our deputy political editor sam
coats
do you think this christmas is going to
be considered better than last christmas
the prime minister proudly kicking off
the festive period turning on the
christmas lights with skilled children
in downing street last week laughing off
questions about a parties said to have
been held in this very street behind
this very door last year
allegra stratton who was to become the
prime minister's press secretary
appearing on tv
now in new footage obtained by itv news
she's seen rehearsing for that role
being asked some difficult questions
about a downing street christmas party
that the inhabitants claimed didn't
happen but listen to the tone just seen
reports from twitter that there was a
downing street christmas party on friday
night do you recognize those reports
i went home
hold on hold on um
uh
uh
would the prime minister condone uh how
are you chris
what's the answer i don't know i didn't
wasn't the party
[Laughter]
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
um one more and then one more um ask
anybody have any questions today there
are plenty more questions asked about
the party she says she went home but
from what and does say in the alleged
party was not socially distanced amount
to a confession each answer leads to a
new question last year at christmas the
public followed the rules and many of
them didn't see their loved ones over
christmas
some of them didn't see their loved ones
again
they had the right to expect the
government to follow the rules and we
now know the government broke the rules
they parted
and now they're laughing about it
they're treating the public with
contempt the prime minister needs to
step up
accept what happened and apologize
unfortunately we've got a prime minister
who is socially distanced from the truth
tory mps are furious this is like
something out of
in the thick of it
if you wrote it
people wouldn't believe it boris johnson
has always been his own man and done his
own thing in his own way i think he has
a certain amount of explaining to do the
leader of the snp in westminster has
actually called for boris johnson to go
over this boris johnson has to resign
you know
everybody followed the covered rules
last year people were told by the
government by boris johnson what they
were expecting to do i'm hearing from
constituents tonight that are just
frankly
ashamed of what has happened here
ashamed but angry too the anger of those
who lost loved ones to covet named on
this wall opposite parliament the fact
that this party took place
is compounding the awfulness
i can't begin to tell you how
the
160 000 families
who have been bereaved by this virus
are feeling right now when we see the
contempt
with which our loved ones lives and our
lives
are treated by this government
it's despicable
it's bad enough that this alleged event
involved three dozen people from downing
street different departments inside
number 10 some people coming in
especially from home in order to attend
i'm told it's bad enough that it took
place two days after london went into
the most severe form of restrictions
known as tier three
what's really worrying tories tonight
however is the spectacle of downing
street aides laughing about an event
that they now deny took place mocking
the very rules that caused such
heartache a year ago
boris johnson took away the nation's
liberties because of covid if it turns
out we weren't all in this together
there could be painful consequences sam
coates sky news
okay so let's just remind you how we got
to this point shall we there have been
continual denials by cabinet ministers
since the first allegation of an illegal
christmas party in downing street on the
30th of november the daily mirror
reported the prime minister gave a
speech at a leaving party where staff
drank wine and took part in a quiz and a
secret santa the next day on the 1st of
december mr johnson was asked about the
allegations at prime minister's
questions by kier stammer three times mr
johnson refused to explicitly deny a
party had taken place by the third of
december the conservative party chair
there he was oliver dowden said the
prime minister had been very clear that
the rules were obeyed at all times here
we go on sunday the deputy prime
minister dominic raab told us here at
sky news that claims of a party were
unsubstantiated
and ever since that initial report
ministers have consistently denied that
a party had taken place
talk to me about what on earth happened
at this party that we keep hearing about
at number 10. uh on sunday you said that
police don't normally quoting you don't
normally look back and investigate
things that have taken place a year ago
yesterday we had the policing minister
on the program he said we should be
investigating anything that is a
historic crime to them the police should
be investigating that where are we today
well so my quote was directly from what
the metropolitan police said this is a
matter for them they said that in
relation to covet regulations they
wouldn't routinely investigate a
retrospective breaches so i would simply
pointing to what the police themselves
have said number 10 have been very clear
there was no party there's been no
breach of the rules
the police get reports all day every day
of things that have happened and they
make a judgment about that and it would
be wrong for me as the policing minister
to seek to have a view
um about the particular police
investigation you know we don't
generally comment on those things but
right you you know we are assured that
i've been assured that everything she
did yesterday and didn't he at the time
the justice secretary did yesterday
and also deputy prime minister he said
if any rules were broken
um then the any if there was a breach of
the rules then it should be investigated
and um if it happened indeed is what he
said but
if it did happen it would be a breach of
tier through tier three rules surely if
a crime potentially had been committed
it should at least be looked into by the
police
well you're asking me to answer a
hypothetical question about this issue
but my general view is that where crime
is reported the police should
investigate
well as you can imagine the story has
made the front pages of the newspapers
this morning a sick joke that's how the
daily mail describes the leaked footage
of the prime minister's former
spokesperson allegra stratton at a
rehearsal press briefing joking about
the idea of a christmas party at downing
street last year guardian also leads
with the story as the accusations of
lying continue to be fired at boris
johnson with the metro describing the
officials in the video as number 10
party clowns the financial times talks
of kierstama condemning the pm accusing
him of having contempt for voters and in
the mirror it's a different tory mp
coming under fire as they lead on an
exclusive about the education secretary
gavin williamson hosting his own
christmas party last year his
spokesperson has admitted and said that
the incident was
unfortunate
well it seems the darning street party
has become a prime time joke with even
anton deck getting in on the act on last
night's i'm a celebrity
it is all change income now though
because yesterday the celebs chose a new
leader via the gift of a secret vault
and that means david's reign is over
but they won't celebrate no they didn't
have a party they categorically deny any
suggestions that they had a party and
this fictional party definitely didn't
involve cheese and wine
or a secret santa
evening prime minister
for now
what you call cut through and despite
the lockdown rules it appears another
member of the cabinet may have held an
office christmas party last year as they
were just hearing the mirror claiming
the former education secretary hosted a
party and gave a speech on the 10th of
december when mixing between households
had been banned in a statement the
department of education says a gathering
took place to thank staff for working
during the pandemic they said looking
back it would have been better not to
have gathered in this way
and goes on footage has emerged of a
current cabinet minister appearing to
mock the allegations of a christmas
party in downing street the video seems
to show the leader of the house of
commons jacob rees-mogg joking about
last year's rules
i see we're all here obeying regulations
aren't we i mean this party is not going
to be investigated by the police in a
year's time you are all you are all very
carefully socially distanced
you have moved i'm pleased to tell you
from the metric back to the imperial
system i know we're at least two inches
as i
understand require
now it's claimed that the party took
place in downing street on the 18th of
december last year just hours after it
is said to have taken place the prime
minister announced millions of people
including in london would be going back
into lockdown
yesterday afternoon i was briefed on the
latest data that shows the virus
spreading
more rapidly in london the southeast and
the east of england than would be
expected given the tough restrictions
that are already in place we will
introduce new restrictions in the most
affected areas specifically those parts
of london the south east and the east of
england which are currently in tier
three
joe is with us this morning good morning
joe um was there a party was there not
not a party and also could there have
been a party and the prime minister not
have known about it i suppose it's
possible what is so confusing about this
is that the denials as we've seen on
your program in recent weeks was were so
clear
and yet
this video also seems to suggest the
complete opposite may have been the case
and the downing street line they were
using last night and for the past few
weeks is still the one they are using i
spoken to press officer downing street
they say that the line is still there
was no christmas party covered rules
have been followed at all times how long
can they stick to that line how long do
you think it's credible they still argue
nothing happened and if nothing happened
why was everyone at that press
conference joking about it it's very
very awkward it's also strange that
there is no minister on the morning
round this morning okay that is very
very rare that there is no government
minister put up to answer the questions
of you other broadcasters certainly the
health secretary was briefly due to come
on this program and on other programs
this morning because it's one year since
margaret keenan was the first person in
the world to receive a code vaccine
outside of a clinical trials well that
was cancelled and other ministerial
visits with media access today have also
been cancelled that doesn't just suggest
that the government are unsure who their
messenger should be at this difficult
time but what their key messages now
they're running out of time to try and
find a key message an excuse a
justification because boris johnson is
your prime minister's questions at 12
kias dharma 100 will have spent uh
yesterday evening and we'll be sending
this morning polishing his jokes his
barbs his zingers to really try and take
advantage of this seeming moment of
weakness on the part of restaurants from
the government the prime minister's had
his back against the wall in the past if
indeed that's how he's viewing it um
this morning he's always come out
smelling of roses um one wonders what
sort of damage this might cause him
i think it
possibly will cause him damage in terms
of his leadership in terms of poll
ratings but what is perhaps more
worrying is the damage it could cause to
confidence in the government's
pandemic strategy if and it is possible
if we have further restrictions and this
affects
the willingness of the public to comply
with restrictions that clearly could be
dangerous for uh public health to refer
to the prime minister there hasn't been
any suggestion that he was at this party
a little bit like uh the dominic
cummings barnard castle
scandal he wasn't there it was somebody
that he worked with who perhaps he
should have managed in a different way
so this is not a scandal at the prime
minister's uh front door even if even if
it took place behind
his front door but it doesn't paint a
good picture of his grasp of detail and
his leadership of these people who were
seemingly having fun when they shouldn't
have been and what about as far as the
met is concerned what are they saying
about all this well they have they have
released a statement saying that they
are aware of this and will look into it
um it is awkward for them because of
course the police surround that building
right the met guard
downing street some may argue could they
have had
no awareness of what was happening there
okay
it's difficult they're in a difficult
position it's always very difficult uh
for the met police when they're talking
about holding those who they guard and
work for to account it's an awkward
relationship but it's possible they'll
uh look into it yeah i mean they're
guarding this street at this very uh
very very very second
yeah all the lights are on interestingly
um i'm guessing there's a lot of um
brain power behind the door at number 10
this morning wondering how to deal with
this it's i think it was alistair
campbell was it who said um if you're on
the front pages for five days about one
story
it's a bit of a challenge and that's the
question what happens next there are
there'll be lots of off-record accounts
of what happened including the fact that
there was a whatsapp message a week in
advance in a follow-up email which
suggests it was premeditated it was
organized it was arranged
could there be
people on record speaking about taking
part in that party could there be photos
could there be videos that would move
the story on further and i think
certainly whatever happens at midday in
the house of commons will move this
story on further because bryce has to
try and justify it yeah number of the
day today is
691 the number of people who died in
hospital the day that video that we've
shown to you this morning was taken
thank you very much indeed we'll talk to
you um later get your take on it as well
at nine o'clock meantime boris johnson
due to face as we were hearing there
from joe mps at prime minister's
questions this lunchtime there'll be
full coverage on sky news from midday
you can have a ringside seat if you'd
like to i bet you do
no still to come on the programme one
year ago since the very first covid
vaccine was given and we are any closer
to ending the
pandemic we'll be asking that of dr
catherine smallwood from the world
health organization she's joining us
shortly
we'll talk to the boss of university
hospital coventry a year since they made
history by giving margaret keenan the
world's first coveted 19 vaccine
twelve days after storm our win and
we'll hear from the village in northern
england where homes either have no power
or just a temporary electricity supply
so as i was saying exactly a year since
margaret keenan became the first person
in the world to get a covered vaccine
tens of millions have been given since
then this morning though scientists in
south africa are warning some current
vaccines may be less effective against
the latest omicron strain a warning this
report from skies iva bennett contains
flash photography from the beginning
i'm just going to be squeezing your arm
okay 90 year old margaret keenan was the
first to receive a coronavirus vaccine
from the nhs a year ago to the day the
number of doses given since then is
nearly 120 million
it's a remarkable achievement made
possible by the hard work of people like
dr anil meta a gp in east london whose
clinic alone has administered 35 000
jabs staying open each night and every
weekend it's been turbulent it's been
full of anxiety
and it's now exhaustion
so it's a mixture of all those emotions
that i've never felt before
working here day in day out for 25 years
that's the magnitude
of what we're talking about
stadiums cinemas churches and mosques
have played their part too among the
numerous venues transformed in the
biggest vaccination drive in nhs history
the scale of the vaccine rollout has
been staggering nearly 3 000 sites like
this have been established across the
country involving more than 200 000 nhs
staff and volunteers but that's the last
12 months the question now is what will
the next 12 bring
the immediate focus is on ramping up the
booster program to tackle the omicron
variant with the nhs launching a major
recruitment drive to find tens of
thousands new staff and
volunteers but at this site in stratford
east london they're struggling to find
patience even among the vulnerable
booster take-up is low
we were doing 1500 a day in the peak
around january february time last year
now we're sort of only doing about 500 a
day at the moment and that's because
patients aren't coming forward
unfortunately there's two reasons i
think one is that people feel that they
have had their first and second
vaccinations and they're fully uh
protected and then there's the omicron
variant which
people feel well the vaccine might not
work for that but we know that the
vaccine is likely to at least help with
the defense against omicrons but how
much protection and for how long still
isn't clear early lab tests from south
africa suggest the pfizer jab may be up
to 40 times less effective against
omicron than the original kovid strain
and with more variants expected next
year scientists say more boosters may be
needed too
we will probably need to boost again and
by then we'll know a lot about our
current vaccines and the vaccines that
are still to be approved and i'm sure we
will be tweaking them and going through
a round of
vaccination again just like with flu
we'll be doing
a top-up vaccine sometime next winter
it is an unwelcome reminder the pandemic
is far from over yet a year from the
first jab it seems we're a long way from
the last iva bennett sky news
what our health correspondent ashish
joshi is in coventry for us this morning
good morning to you
we've come such a long way in a year but
from what we're hearing this morning in
south africa still a long way to go
yes that's a reminder if one were needed
that the vaccine which offered us so
much hope
exactly a year ago today that there is
some way to go to finally seeing out
this pandemic we may be in a position
where we will be taking boosters for
years to come and that's the nature of
the coronavirus today margaret keenan
the first patient she'll be here telling
us about the years she's had and also
made parsons the first nurse who
administered that vaccine she's here too
talking about the challenges that she
and her staff have faced over what's
been a very difficult year for the
national health service the question now
okay is do we go back to what we saw at
the beginning of the vaccine rollout
will we see mass vaccination centers
trying to ramp up the booster program
because that really does seem to be
effective against the new omicron
variants and
results coming from south africa
yesterday saying or suggesting at least
it's a very small sample study but the
first scientific tests on omicron
suggesting there was a degree
of vaccine evasion now that will worry
the scientists but the manufacturers are
convinced that they can tweak their
vaccines to deal with even this variance
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot are looking at the latest
daily covered data for you it's looking
something like this 45
new cases of covid19 recorded in the
last 24 hours another 180 deaths have
been reported within 28 days of a
positive test that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk to 145
thousand eight hundred and twenty six
nineteen thousand nine hundred and
seventy nine people received their first
dose of a vaccine while twenty five
thousand and twelve people received
their second dose that means the total
number of people to have received their
second doses is more than 46 and a half
million
almost 330 000 booster and third jabs
were given in the latest 24-hour period
taking the total number of those doses
to more than 28 million
also this morning sky news has seen
evidence that some vaccine certificates
and passes which could be used by people
coming into the uk are fake we've
discovered we've discovered forgive me
that false documents are being
advertised for sale in at least nine
european countries
kate barnfield is in the newsroom for us
this morning hello to you kate good
morning so what more do we know about
these fake vaccine passports
good morning kay well as you say sky
news data unit has uncovered some really
worrying evidence that criminals are
capitalizing on stricter coronavirus
rules being introduced across europe and
what these criminal gangs appear to be
doing are selling fake eu digital covert
certificates and what they are basically
a pass
that people in europe can get on their
phone for instance with a qr code
that proves that they are vaccinated or
have had a negative test and the problem
is that people can actually use these
passes to fill out the uk's passenger
locator form so people theoretically
could be coming here
without actually having had a
vaccination or a negative test at all
now this investigation has also
uncovered evidence uh that
disinformation about vaccines are being
used to sell these passes so posts like
this one for example advertising covered
passes in countries close to the uk like
belgium and france describe the passes
as the alternative to getting vaccinated
and many adverts also use misinformation
about the side effects of vaccines to
convince users to pay for fake covert
passes this one for example states that
jabs lead to death well sky news data
and forensics units found adverts for
these passes in nine european countries
adwords for adverts were found posted in
groups of more than a hundred thousand
users with some advertisers claiming to
be doctors passes are typically listed
for around 300 euros that's 255 pounds
at a time with untraceable payments like
bitcoin being offered and it is a
growing problem with the australian the
austrian government warning they
detected 500 fake passes in november as
they introduce new covert restrictions
well sky news has spoken to police
officers uh in italy who are working
with disinformation units like this and
they say they are now investigating
okay thanks a lot ketty thank you
the australian prime minister says his
country will join the united states in a
diplomatic boycott of next year's
beijing winter olympics let's get more
detail from our asia correspondent tom
cheshire who's in beijing tom we've been
talking about this all week and the
pressure political pressure certainly is
continuing to ratchet up
it really is i don't think australia is
necessarily a surprise k the relations
between
china and australia at all-time low
australia had the temerity uh to suggest
there should be an independent
investigation into the origins of covert
19 and china reacted furiously i put all
sorts of tariffs on imports very hard to
find a bottle of australian red wine
here in beijing so scott morrison coming
out and saying that he would be joining
this diplomatic boycott it's not a full
sporting boycott the athletes will be
that isn't a surprise he referenced the
relationship between the two countries
but also china's
human rights abuses as he described them
here's what he had to say about earlier
i very much separate the issues of sport
and and these other political issues
their issues between two governments and
i would like to see those issues
resolved but they are not resolved and
australia will not step back from the
strong position we've had standing up
for australia's interests and consistent
with that position then obviously it is
of no surprise that we wouldn't be
sending australian officials to those
games
china's not having any of that its
embassy in canberra said that as
everyone knows australia is solely
responsible for the current plight of
sino-australia relations and australia's
decision not to send officials to the
beijing winter olympics runs counter to
its public statements of so-called hopes
that china australia's relations could
improve so we've seen the u.s do this
and we've seen on trailer do i think for
different reasons now the focus is going
to be on the uk which is in a bit of a
more difficult space you've got the us
which is a very powerful country which
can do what it wants australia thinking
maybe it doesn't have anything to lose
the uk is right in the middle of that
and we're still awaiting a decision on
whether the uk is going to join that
diplomatic boycott of the winter
olympics
okay thank you thanks a lot
now after the heavy winds and heavy
rains forecasters say that storm barrow
will bring ice and freezing temperatures
to much of the uk today winds yesterday
reached speeds of 86 miles
an hour
so what else could we do apart from send
ender to port call in south wales hang
on in there how's it looking oh goodness
me look at all that from the sea
yeah good morning kay we're live here on
the seafront in port call in south wales
day two of storm baron as you were
saying the highest wind speeds yesterday
in wales across the whole of the uk in
fact 86 miles per hour in aberdaren
in gwyneth so here in port call we saw
wind speeds touching 70 miles per hour
yesterday we spent
a good deal of yesterday with the local
rnli crew volunteers and they were just
monitoring conditions at sea and there
were waves seven meters high uh off the
coast of port call yesterday and the
wind conditions made the storm
conditions looking uh pretty much gale
force 11 off the coast of south wales
yesterday so huge disruption across the
country and one school in clinetally
yesterday isca brinwin had part of its
roof blown off uh just around four
o'clock so thankfully the children had
left the school at that point so repairs
will be getting underway there today
infinitely but uh day two of storm barra
we're still about an hour and a half
away from high tide if i just step out
of the way here and we'll leave you with
a shot of just what the sea is doing a
lot of foam just blowing its way in here
but uh day two of storm borough and i'm
told transport for wales are
implementing their emergency timetable
um 70 train services cancelled across
wales already this morning
that's what seafoam looks like with 70
mile an hour winds look after yourself
thanks a lot ender thank you
uh what's it like for the rest of us
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well stormborough may well continue to
bring some disruption to ireland and
southwest britain today but it won't be
stormy like yesterday it's a cold windy
and showery start with snow on northern
hills but southeast england is mainly
dry rather cloudy through the morning
with further showers or longer spells of
rain but there'll be some brightness in
the far south expect more wintriness on
northern hills
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still no word from downing street this
morning following fresh allegations of a
christmas party taking place during
lockdown last december a leaked video
appears to show staff discussing a party
as they rehearsed a media briefing in
the downing street press room the
briefing was being led by the prime
minister's then spokesperson allegra
stratton
joe is uh with us heard anything else
from downing street nothing at all okay
and there are many um answer questions
on this firstly whether they're uh lying
that nothing happened there was no
christmas party will change but if
something did happen you know who was
there who was the most senior figure
certainly reports suggest that there
were many dozens of uh people who were
there and there then could there be
pressure on
them some talk that it was just civil
servants if special advisers or even
ministers were there this could be far
more problematic but as i say danny when
i spoke to them this morning and this
hasn't changed say there was no
christmas party covered rules have been
followed at all times i think that's the
sustainable position though is it okay
especially since they don't seem to be
confident enough in their position to
put a minister up on the morning round
to defend it we knew that saudi jared
the health secretary was supposed to be
on that round this morning talking about
covid uh vaccines with this one-year
anniversary since margaret keenan got
her jab we know that other ministers
have cancelled media access to their
visits today but the one person who
cannot get away from scrutiny is boris
johnson who's up in the commons at
midday for pmq's okay um so how much of
a challenge is this for the prime
minister could he find himself in a
position where he's saying
and stick to the position i didn't know
there was a party if there was a party
this is the first i heard about it or is
that not sustainable and also what about
the police
i think what what his team will want to
do is try and distance boris johnson
from all of this of course
is that possible we don't know who was
there we don't know if he popped in to
say hello and had a glass if if an event
actually took place without knowing the
details it's hard to understand how far
they can distance boris johnson from all
of this but they'll want to do that as
much as possible to sort of not allow
him to be dragged down with it in terms
of the police the met have said they are
aware of the footage it's their policy
not to routinely investigate
retrospective breaches however they say
the footage that we saw last night will
form part of their consideration they're
in a difficult position because they
protect a downing street and perhaps
some of their officers saw signs that a
party could have been taking place one
wonders if i mean and i don't know maybe
the met will tell us but you know if
they didn't know that there were a lot
of people inside downey street why not i
suppose would be a question i would ask
the commissioner if she was on the show
maybe she'll come on who knows if you're
watching commissioner good morning come
and join us we'll see you at eight
o'clock thanks very much indeed now a
year on since the first corona virus
vaccine and there is growing concern
this morning about the omicron strain
scientists in south africa say some
existing vaccines may be less effective
against the latest mutation with us now
is the world health organization's
europe covid 19 lead and that's dr
catherine smallwood doctor good morning
to you thank you for joining us how
worried is the world health organization
about the omicron variant
hi hi doctor can you hear me okay
okay we'll go back to the doctor in just
a second can you hear me now doctor
nope i don't think she can we'll go back
to the doctor in just a second or two
sort that one out for you uh meantime we
will be going to downing street again in
just a few moments time
we should have had sadie jabed on the
program this morning to talk about the
vaccine a year since the very first
astrazeneca vaccine was administered at
a coventry hospital
and um he should have been on the
program to tell us what happened then
what's happened since what's going to
happen next a couple of times we're told
he was coming on sadly he um no one's
answering the phone now not sure why but
uh what we do know is that other um
press access to ministers has also been
cancelled or postponed at events around
the country today
as far as the prime minister is
concerned um i can't really get away
from further scrutiny today he will be
facing the leader of the opposition
across the dispatch box at 12 o'clock
for prime minister's questions
meantime let's see if dr catherine is
with us now hello to you doctor
hi there good morning hi sorry about
that those gremlins have pesky there's
time in the morning
how worried are you about the omicron
variant
we're pretty worried which is why we
declared it um
very quickly a variant of concern which
is um our highest classification of
concern for new variants of sales cov2
and uh that classification was warranted
because we're now seeing it spread
um in a lot of countries around the
world and in europe the european region
in particular where we have at least 21
countries um having reported confirmed
cases and now we're seeing community
transmission quite quick spread
among a handful of countries including
in the uk
but no severe symptoms no
hospitalizations no deaths
is this the
normal way that we see with a virus it
develops the first strain is a big
challenge we see others that pop up and
then eventually they begin begin to wane
could we could this but can we see this
as a positive in other words
well we can't conclude that it's milder
than delta at the moment um certainly a
lot of us hope that it might be but the
evidence isn't there yet we need to wait
a little more time to understand the
clinical progression in the cases that
we're picking up we've seen this spread
very quickly and we're really in a
matter of 10 days since it was first
identified so
we're still at the stage of looking at
the clinical data it may well turn out
to result in more hospitalizations we do
have a couple of hospitalizations in the
european region already
of cases confirmed with omicron but we
do have reason to believe that all of
the measures that we have
um at our availability will still be
functioning so this is really important
that people continue to do what they've
been doing for covid19 to protect
themselves and to protect others
and it was the right decision um to
prevent african countries 11 countries
now in nigeria i think the latest one to
be added to the list to be prevent them
and the people of those countries from
moving around the world
well measures taken at borders are
obviously the prerogative of member
states and what's position is that
travel bans won't prevent omicron from
spreading and i think that's
very clearly displayed that in less than
that less than a week we have over 50
countries around the world reporting
omicron now and uh and it won't
certainly um stop the the variant from
spreading um it won't respect travel
bans it will continue to spread now
there may be some impact of increased
testing and
increased measures around travelers that
could lead to slowing that
spread but measures need to be taken at
home
um if we didn't have the vaccine where
would we be today
well in the uk um we would be with far
far far higher numbers of people dying
every week from covert 19. in the
european region
we've conducted a study of 33 countries
we found that the vaccines between
december and november this year saved
close to half a million people's lives
in england
that's close or over 150 000 in scotland
that's a high number as well and
we've seen that countries that have
implemented really good vaccination
campaigns where vaccination among high
risk groups have been reached quickly
and to high levels have saved more lives
than others but we have to remember that
saving lives and controlling
transmission depends on a lot more than
just the vaccination
and especially with a new
variant such as omicron that may have
some level of immune escape
we need to continue to rely on
everything
in addition to vaccines to keep
transmission under control in the uk at
the moment the vaccines have offered the
uk a huge amount of protection but a
decrease in that protection would then
mean that other measures become more
important
okay professor doctor forgive me it's
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us a year ago today
thank you since margaret keenan was the
first person in the world to get the
astrazeneca
vaccine professor andy hardy ceo of
university hospital coventry and
warwickshire uhcw hello to you thank you
for joining us this morning
professor you heard there what the
representative from the who the world
health organization had to say a lot of
acronyms uh this morning um your view on
where we'd be if we didn't have the
vaccine
well firstly good morning kate it's good
to be with you um well quite simply
and very clearly the vaccine has been
the game changer we hoped it would be
that doesn't mean the game's over
but it still is the main defense we've
got against this disease in the spread
of this disease and that's why it's
fantastic we're celebrating a year on
now since this first vaccine which we
were honored to host here in coventry
and you know if i've got one message
today is that we need to
ensure as many people come forward for
their boosters or even their first or
second doses of them had it to date
how concerned are you professor about
the omicron variant
i think has just been said it's still
very very early days
literally two three weeks since we first
heard about this variant
and it's fantastic as ever that the
scientists are working to get an
understanding about how transmittable it
is
whether or not it escapes vaccines and
what the actual effects are in terms of
symptoms and how will people become
early signs are hopefully encouraging i
think we do know that uh the vaccine
even if it's not as effective as it is
against some of the other it will be
effective and that's why it is really
important that we keep pushing
vaccination program and as i said the
early signs are that it would appear
that people aren't getting too ill but
it is such a small sample we've heard
off so far we just need to keep an eye
on it
and what's the um situation current
situation professor as far as beds
available availability is as far as beds
are concerned in your area
okay um well beds are always challenged
this time of year due to winter
pressures etc i think it's put into
context for covid patients
so in my hospital we've got 1200 beds of
which at the moment 35 are taken up with
cobia patients and if you go back to the
peak back in january february this year
that was in excess of 260. um so there
are beds available it's tight it's
always tight this time of year and it's
always in management and they're
measuring where we need to go on a
day-to-day basis but at the moment we're
confident that we can deal with what's
coming our way
um okay and as far as those you said
that the number of beds that were taken
up with covered patients what sort of um
what sort of
covered patients are we looking at is it
pregnant moms who've not been vaccinated
is it older people what are we looking
at
there's always a few number of older
people but but very clearly we are
starting to see
an increased proportion of our kobe
patients who need hospital treatment and
importantly critical care
intervention are those who are
unvaccinated and and and that is true
there are a number of those who have
been pregnant ladies and of course we
know that can affect both the mum and
the baby so again it comes back to the
importance of the vaccination it does
make a difference it stops people
getting hospitalized it starts people
needing critical care it stops people
needing that most you know almost
intervention
have you had your booster professor
i certainly have yeah very proud decided
yeah
and
to those who are a little bit concerned
about having it
um i would say just speak to some
professionals professionals are willing
to
talk to you help and help you understand
your fears and talk through the positive
sides of this and actually talking about
pregnant ladies that's a great example
to start with we know that the social
media around both the potential effects
of the vaccine on fertility and our
people who are pregnant was very
negative but we
very very clear the opposite is true now
if you're uh
somebody wants to become pregnant if you
are pregnant you are so much better off
in terms of your own safety and the
safety of your baby to have the vaccine
so please come and get it we are waiting
in the nhs to do as many jobs as people
come forward for
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for allowing us to visit
your hospital as well today thank you
thank you
more on our top story this morning for
you now the leaked video which appears
to show senior downing street staff
joking about attending a christmas
office party during lockdown last
december we're joined by the
conservative mp sir roger gail sir roger
thank you for joining us on
the program i'm guessing you've seen the
video what did you make of it
i was completely incredulous
um i cannot believe that
i've said it
if this was in the thick of it
then people wouldn't believe it
it would be a joke
unfortunately it's not funny
the prime minister
we can't say that he was there we can't
say that he knew anything
about it it could just be that he's been
massively let down by his team if indeed
there was a party
it could certainly be that he's been
massively let down but he's the prime
minister and he ought to know
dining street at the moment is saying
there was no party as i understand it
i would like to hear the prime minister
come to the dispatch box at prime
minister's question time today
and in answer to the questions that will
no doubt be asked
say point blank there was no party and
to say that on the record if he says
that i will believe him
because to
deliberately mislead the house
if that turned out to be the case would
be a resignation matter
he said yesterday in a media round that
there was no party
a christmas party and that all rules
covered rules had been abided by at
downing streets is that not enough or do
you think that because he's uh says it
in the palace of westminster that his
feet are held to the fire there
the prime minister has to either say
there was a party he didn't know about
it and he apologizes
or he has to say on the record at the
dispatch box there was no party we have
to move forward for why
because if we are going to beat a micron
then the government is going to have to
take probably
some further measures people have to
comply with those measures and be able
to and feel that they are able to comply
and if we're getting one message from
downing street
and another message from government
then people are not going to do as
they're asked and that is serious that
means that the health service could be
in trouble and people's lives could be
at stake
i think one of the concerns from people
that we have spoken to is that
everything seemed to be quite
light-hearted in the video people were
laughing and joking um about uh covert
restrictions um we heard um
jacob rees-mogg who is a very senior
member of the conservative party as we
know uh he seems to have been filmed
secretly also making a joke about covid
restrictions what's your view on that
well people do make jokes uh we have to
remember that this was a dry run
rehearsal for allegra stratton
apparently
um and that it was downing street staff
not the press corps who were asking the
questions
and inevitably under those circumstances
as probably a degree of black humor i
understand that entirely um people are
allowed to laugh occasionally um some of
us don't do too much maybe not enough
um we are we are allowed to be
irreverent doctors are irreverent they
have to be they have to stay sane
somehow
so i i don't have any quarrel with that
at all what i do have a quarrel with
is the idea that this party and i'm told
by sources
that
food was taken in the drink was taken in
that entertainment
was had and if that is so that sounds to
me pretty much like a party we cannot
this is a barnard castle moment
potentially isn't it we cannot say one
thing
and do another
we have to be believed we have to be
trusted
because at the end of the day we have to
carry people with us
to do or not do
some things that may be very
inconvenient indeed and i suspect
that between now and christmas there may
be
downstream more more restrictions
introduced if that is so we've got to
carry the country with us in everybody's
sake for the sake of people's lives
that matters
so this background noise that's going on
at the moment
has to be put behind us and the only
person who can do that definitively
i believe is the prime minister from the
dispatch box
today a minister have
done what ministers always do and speak
to people like me and my colleagues on
other channels this morning to explain
what happened and be the mouthpiece for
number 10 downing street wasn't today a
day to put their big boy and big girl
pants on
i don't control the um
the media output from conservative
central office i don't know how you make
your bids or who you bid for um i
believe in saying what i think and i'm
saying what i think i'm prepared to do
it on my own behalf and by the way i'm
doing it on my own behalf i'm not
speaking for my colleagues or the party
or anybody else i haven't discussed it i
haven't had time um i haven't even been
to the tea room this morning so i don't
know what people are saying but i'm
telling you what i think
that's as far as i'm prepared to go i
can't tell you what anybody else thinks
but i can tell you what i think
a lot of um
communication on twitter yesterday um
you could say oh that's just twitter but
that's where a lot of people air their
views and even last night we saw the cut
through
on primetime television where um two of
our you know
much-loved treasures british treasures
were making fun of the prime minister
and his policies when you get to that
stage
some very hard questions have to be
answered
well i think some hard questions have to
be answered for the sake of the nation
because as i've
said now a couple of times
we have a hard road ahead with co-micron
we have to beat it
and we have to try and enable people
and business
but also in their domestic lives to have
a decent christmas
and we can only do that if we're
carrying people with us if people
understand the sense of direction we've
got to the message has to be we've got
to get people vaccinated
clowns that haven't been vaccinated need
to understand that this is important and
they need to go and get vaccinated the
people who haven't had second vaccines
need to have those and the people who've
had those need to get their boosters and
that is the message that we all ought to
be concentrating on get out there and in
the interest of not yourself
but of the people around you the people
you love get yourself vaccinated
so that you don't become a condit for
micron
and if we can do that
then we can have a decent christmas
that's what matters
and all this as i said all this
background noise is getting in the way
of the real message
which is what we all ought to be
concentrating on
okay um so roger i'm afraid we must
leave it there but it's very interesting
to talk to you this morning thank you
for taking the time thank you
thank you
electricity officials in northern
england have not yet confirmed they have
kept their promise to reconnect all
homes cut off by storm irwin 12 days ago
there's concern the recovery operation
will be further delayed by bad weather
from stormborough joining us now
jonathan stop
left without power for 10 days after
storm armin he was delivered a generator
after appearing on this program a few
days ago but it hasn't been the
smoothest of experiences hi tell us what
happened thanks for joining us again
thank you kay um as you can imagine
there's
feelings of joy and a little bit of
relief in the village here for us um
over the last couple of days um the the
northern power grid did turn up they
provided us with a generator it took a
little while to get it set up and
running but um but they did deliver uh
for us after i appeared on the news a
couple of days ago um so we had power i
think on monday evening at about 20 past
10. um they've been a couple of glitches
and we've had to have the emergency
response team dispatch just this morning
to to get the generator up and running
and i have heard rumblings on social
media of generators running out of power
and whatnot um i think one of the key
things to remember there's a lot of
communities up here who are still
running on temporary power supplies you
know generators and so on um you know
the the problems are far from fixed as
it were um there's still a clear a lot
of work to do and northern power grid
can't quite relax just yet i don't think
uh how are you about you about the next
storm storm barra that is coming
barreling in
so far we've had some fairly strong
winds here um if i'm honest you know
nothing compared to the skill of storm
that we experienced with uh
with storms two weeks ago um hopefully
you know they won't come anywhere near
it we're very conscious of the frontline
workers and engineers who are out in
those you know gale force winds expected
to make repairs and keep people
connected as well and so you know
praying for their safety and make we
don't want them to be put at risk um so
like i said i think we're just hunkering
down and hoping for the best really and
making sure that uh none of those
temporary power supplies get affected
and cut people off for weeks and weeks
again yeah um i'm glad you've got your
power back i'm glad they were watching
um
if there's any further problems you know
where we are at yours thank you so much
thank you we really appreciate it thank
you so much not at all thanks a lot for
joining us thank you
coming up in just a few minutes time
we're going to be joined by the shadow
foreign secretary david lammy as we get
labour's reaction to the allegations of
a party last christmas in downing street
now
the prime minister
uh and his senior ministers have been
telling us over the last few days that a
party didn't happen it just didn't
happen what are you talking about it
didn't happen and
whatever was happening at downing street
was certainly within uh covert
regulations i spoke to the deputy prime
minister about it just yesterday and he
said definitely didn't happen a tape a
video emerged last night
of
senior aides at downing street who were
laughing and joking about how to deal
with press enquiries if they were asked
about a party at dining street they said
that they may describe it as a cheese
and wine gathering
or that they had gone home
what happens next stay tuned and find
out
[Music]